monsieur le ministre bonsoir on sait que
l'ordre dans les prisons n'est pas de
votre ressort mais bien celui du garde
des sceaux cependant ce sont vos
policiers qui assurent l'ordre autour
des prisons si les gardiens de prisons
décident de quitter leur travail est ce
que vous enverriez vos policiers pour
les remplacer malheureusement l'ordre
dans les prisons relève des forces de
police ou de gendarmerie lorsqu'il ya
des ordres dans les prisons je crois que
les discussions que pierre arpaillange
le garde des sceaux a entrepris avec les
principales organisations syndicales des
fonctionnaires de l'administration
pénitentiaire devrait aboutir à la
solution raisonnable qui évitera de
poser ce genre de problème si sa trace
mais bien sûr c'est mon souhait je pense
que c'est le souhait de tous les
français et que les gardiens de prison
qui ont un métier très difficile très
dur
peu connus seront trouvées avec pierre
arpaillange tête un homme de dialogue
une solution ce serait tout à fait
déplorable parce que la situation
actuelle elle est mauvaise pour tout le
monde y compris pour la démocratie je
veux dire pour les droits de la défense
pour les familles pour il faut éviter
les scènes de violence que
malheureusement on a pu voir il ya
quelques heures
alors revenons si j'ose dire sur notre
terrain les obsèques de la petite
ludivine découverte morte et violet
avant-hier à clermont ferrand ont eu
lieu aujourd'hui
les policiers ne semblent pas avoir de
pistes sérieuses dès hier soir dans ce
journal votre directeur des polices
urbaines nous disait qu'on ne pouvait
pas déduire de cette recrudescence de
meurtres d'enfants une véritable un
véritable phénomène statistiques mais on
en parle
alors face à l' angoisse des parents
qu'est ce que vous faites
ces crimes c'est à dire assassinat de
mineur avec violences sexuelles sont
très rares le diable soit très rare et
son horrible il nous choque
il provoque une compassion à l'égard des
enfants bien sûr des parents et ils
frappent profondément l'opinion publique
c'est normal même s'ils sont très rares
l'année dernière il y en a eu six
l'année d'avant mais n'avait eu 3 nous
voulons la voir une série de quatre
en les musiques étaient cependant
quelques semaines mais alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait les mesures à prendre sont
évidemment des mesures de police et sur
les quatre il y en avoir lieu dans deux
cas les forces de police ou de
gendarmerie ont interpellé les auteurs
présumés de ces crimes
on ne peut pas se contenter de ça les
mesures de prévention je peux vous
donner quelques exemples
j'en ai parlé cet après midi avec le
premier ministre michel rocard et avec
le neige au spa nous pensons qu'une
action d'information de sensibilisation
que madame barak le ministre de la
famille avait déjà évoqué dans une
communication récente l'action en faveur
des enfants il faut les protéger en
général y compris les protéger contre
les genres de menaces très rare mais
très grave
il ya par exemple nous allons préparer
madame barzakh monsieur jospin et moi
même une brochure à destination des
parents et donc des enfants adam barzakh
était bien le ministre de la santé du
maïs et d'herbe gouvernement voulait
dire merde orlhac la dame d'aures
laquelle lapsus il ya si peu de femmes
dans les gouvernements de foire les
romains jolie madame dorlhac merci de
m'avoir corriger mais ça peut aussi
concerner le ministre de la santé car on
est devant un problème qui concerne ce
sont des fous qui s'attaque à des
enfants dans ces conditions mais donc
c'est mieux protéger les enfants et pour
protéger les enfants
il faut informer les parents il faut que
les précautions concernant la
surveillance des enfants soient
renforcés c'est la sphère de la pole et
concrètement ça veut dire quoi plus ici
près des écoles à faire de la police
c'est la sphère de l'école c'est la
sphère de la famille c'est la sphère de
la société tout entier à protéger les
enfants
nous adressons aux associations de
parents d'élèves aux élus au comité de
prévention pour qu'une action se fait
pour protéger les enfants contre ce
genre d'agression alors on nous parlait
de deux brochures d'information pourquoi
parce que souvent on a le sentiment que
toutes les prisons ne sont pas prises
pour mettre les enfants à l'abri de ce
genre d'agression donc commençons par
éduquer les parents et surtout l'
urgence on part nous interroger sur une
société dans laquelle les enfants ont
besoin d'une protection qui ne peut pas
être assurée seulement par la police moi
quand je mets des centaines de forces de
police supplémentaires aux sorties
d'école
je ne répondant parfaitement aux
problèmes si les gendarmes dans les
campagnes surveille davantage les
enfants on ne répond qu'un parfaitement
à ce problème et c'est une question qui
interpelle toute la société c'est pour
ça ce soir
je voudrais dire que nous avons
certainement un effort à faire pour
l'accueil des enfants des écoles
je vous parlais de salaire de madame
dorlhac vous m'avez repris sur mon
lapsus mais temps de ministre de la
famille temps de ministre de la santé
depuis tant d'années connaissent ce
problème de la protection des enfants
qu'il faut bien se dire que ce n'est pas
uniquement une question de ministres
d'administrations de services mais de
réflexion de la société la protection
inévitablement vous le savez ce genre
d'affaires provoque la réouverture d'un
débat celui de la peine de mort pourtant
aboli en france 180 le député du front
national suggère un référendum sur les
questions du côté de vos prédécesseurs
et adversaires politiques les opinions
sont partagées
j'ai des contres comme l'individu comme
simple citoyen faire de conscience et je
dirais même tu sens une façon affaire de
tripes
j'ai fait voter une loi en 86 qui
prévoyait une peine de substitution la
peine de mort et je dois en connaître
que c'est un échec c'est une illusion
parce que il n'y a pas en réalité de
peine qui puisse remplacer la peine de
mort
y'a rien de plus odieux que les
assassinats concernant les enfants qui
sont des êtres sans défense qui par
nature sont confiants et ceux qui ceux
qui commettent de tels assassinats ne
doivent avoir aucune pitié et la société
a le devoir de se défendre et je crois
que le moment est venu de
montrer que la société ait décidé à
utiliser tous les moyens
et moi je suis partisan dans ce domaine
du rétablissement de la peine de mort
monsieur jacques un débat qui n'a pas
lieu de rouvrir tous les français savent
que la peine de mort n'existe plus dans
aucun pays d'europe et il est à la porte
et d'aucuns ministre d'aucun parlement
en france ni d'ailleurs dans aucun pays
d'europe de rétablir la peine de mort
qui dorénavant interdites par une
convention internationale et par
conséquent c'est vrai que les crimes
contre les êtres sans défense contre les
enfants contre les personnes âgées sont
particulièrement odieux mais ce n'est
pas la peine de mort qui est en cause
c'est la protection des enfants la
protection des faibles et ça c'est une
affaire qui concerne la société et qui
ne concerne pas seulement les bourreaux
et les guillotines un dernier point
monsieur joc sur un autre registre la
corse
un comité interministériel a été
annoncée hier qui doit entreprendre une
action à long terme pour développer les
ressources de l'ine les réactions
politiques et syndicales sont positives
à votre initiative
l'ex effet l'insee confirmé dans la nuit
une prolongation à déterminer de la
trêve des attentats
alors pour vous c'est un premier
résultat ou une espèce de pacte
préétabli pas de pacte mais tout recul
de la violence c'est une grande victoire
de la démocratie et ceux qui en corse
on pensait qu'il trouverait par la
violence un certain nombre de solutions
aux problèmes de cette région que sur
les problèmes difficiles eh bien s'ils
acceptent de considérer qu' il faut
abandonner la violence c'est une
victoire pour tout le monde y compris
d'ailleurs pour eux mêmes il mesure que
vous mettez en place en corse en
particulier contre la fraude électorale
elles vont encore être plus rigides
alors là vous savez si je peux extirper
la fraude électorale là où elles
existent que ce soit en corse ou
ailleurs qui n'est pas con corse
ce sera aussi une grande victoire de la
démocratie mais je pense que cela dépend
de tous les citoyens
ce sont les citoyens qui peuvent par
leur présence dans les bureaux de vote
par leur assistance au dépouillement par
leur vigilance par leur exigence faire
disparaître la fraude électorale qui
déshonorent un pays lorsqu'il existe
trop monsieur jacques merci et je
rappelle que
second tour des élections cantonales
aura lieu dimanche prochain